rêver j'imagine que vous avez tous des
rêves
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler de
mon rêve parce que je suis persuadé que
vous allez m'aider à le réaliser
j'ai toujours rêvé d'un monde où les
hommes sont en parfaite harmonie avec la
nature
ou comme toutes les espèces nous sommes
adaptés et adaptable à notre
environnement où nous ne perturbons
aucun des merveilleuses cycle de l'eau
si que des saisons cycle de la vie nous
n'avons aucun impact négatif ne
produisons aucune pollution ni aucun
déchet parce que c'est quoi un déchet un
déchet c'est quelque chose qui nous est
plus utile dont on n'a plus besoin c'est
tout ce qui peut être solides liquides
ou gazeux et que nous rejetons dans
notre environnement
en parlant de ça ne serions nous pas les
seuls sur terre à avoir cette notion
même de déchets si nous sommes les seuls
dans la nature rien n'est considérée
comme telle tout absolument tout faire à
quelqu'un ou à quelque chose pour créer
la vie en fait c'est ça j'ai toujours
rêvé d'un monde zéro déchet mais alors
utopie ou réalité
lorsque j'avais 10 ans j'habitais à la
montagne et j'adorais aller me balader
en forêt et regarder les feuilles des
arbres tombés au sol devenir de l'humus
grâce à des vers de terre qui sont
mangés par les oiseaux qui eux mêmes
sont mangés par des mammifères et qui
eux-mêmes permettent aux arbres et aux
plantes de pousser de nouveaux
en se basant sur ce modèle vertueux de
la vie vous faire imaginer un monde où
il n'y a aucun déchet serait totalement
dingue et utopique
c'est donc très concrètement ce que je
vais essayer de vous faire faire je vous
propose
si ça peut vous aider de fermer les yeux
et d'imaginer
imaginez un monde où tous les objets de
votre quotidien sont là pour toute votre
vie
imaginez que vous lever le matin que
vous habillé avec des vêtements durable
éthique que vous prenez un petit
déjeuner avec des produits bons pour
votre santé
bon pour l'environnement que vous
habitez dans un bâtiment durable et éco
conçus que vous partez travailler avec
un moyen de locomotion non polluants
imaginez qu'en plus vous travaillez pour
un métier qui vous tient à coeur qui
répondent à vos valeurs sur les plans
social sociétal économiques ou
environnementaux imaginez qu'en plus
vous êtes impliqué dans toutes les
décisions de votre ville de votre
territoire
imaginez que tout ça que tout ça vous
arrivez à le faire aussi dans votre pays
dans votre monde
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux pour ce
qu'ils avaient fermé ok j'ai peut-être
un peu légèrement dépassé le cadre du
zéro déchet quoique quoique tout dépend
de ce qu'on se considère réellement
comme un déchet lorsque j'avais 15 ans
j'ai pris conscience que ce monde
utopique n'était pas vraiment le monde
réel et je me suis dit qu'en fait
l'homme aujourd'hui un impact partout
sur la nature et j'ai voulu comprendre
pourquoi
pourquoi et comment est-ce qu'on en
était arrivé là et finalement j'ai
repensé à tout ce que j'avais pu voir à
l'école le big bang la création de la
vie les animaux l'homme l'antiquité le
moyen âge l'industrialisation la
mondialisation la consommation la
surconsommation et l'hyperconsommation
d'aujourd'hui bref l'homme a toujours
évolué et évoluent toujours parce que si
nous sommes les seuls à avoir cette
notion de déchet nous sommes aussi les
seuls à pouvoir imaginer notre société
de demain
finalement le monde d'aujourd'hui c'est
le rêve des hommes d'hier lorsque
j'avais 20 ans comme vous je finissais
mes études d'ingénieur et j'avais aussi
envie de me dire de me représenter
qu'est ce que c'était mon impact amoa
personnel parce que finalement qu'est-ce
qu'on voit on voit notre poubelle on
voit notre voiture
on voit notre facture d'eau
d'électricité mais on se rend rarement
content de tout ce qui peut y avoir
derrière
je prends un exemple un jean et on va
essayer de tirer de dérouler la pelote
pour remonter derrière tout ce qui peut
y avoir derrière un jean votre jeans
vous voyez bien qu'il est composé de
plusieurs matériaux du tissu du fil
dérivé des boutons une fermeture éclair
qui potentiellement proviennent des
quatre coins du monde
votre jean lui-même il a été transporté
il a été tenté ce qui a utilisé des
procédés des produits chimiques et
toxiques
ce ce tissu a été tissée filet à partir
de coton et là aussi ça a demandé des
procédés qui y ont qui demande
énormément d'énergie de l'énergie
généralement possible
et puis le coton il a poussé dans un
champ un champ qui a demandé de l'eau
beaucoup beaucoup d'eau
et même des engrais des pesticides et on
peut aussi remonter derrière comment ont
été créés ces engrais comment était
importé ces pesticides
et puis votre jeans il a été emballé
dans du plastique potentiellement qui
lui aussi a été extrait raffiné
transformer et comme ça on peut remonter
vraiment très largement un seul jean
c'est plus de onze mille litres d'eau un
seul jean c'est plus de une fois le tour
de la terre
rien qu'en transport un seul jeans et
des quantités et des quantités d'énergie
que je n'arrivais même pas à vous
exprimer
[Musique]
et ça cette réflexion
vous pouvez la voir avec tous les objets
de votre quotidien
votre smartphone peugeot sur votre
canapé votre télé peu de voitures tout
est là on commence à comprendre pourquoi
est ce qu'il y a ses montagnes et ses
montagnes de déchets même si elles sont
à l'autre bout du monde
comment il peut y avoir dans les océans
ces animaux torturés emprisonnés dans
des déchets ces microplastiques ces
pollutions ces feux de forêt parce que
vous vous rendez compte qu'on déploie
toute notre technologie notre énergie
notre génie à aller puiser dans nos
ressources pour que tous finissent à la
poubelle
mais la vraie réalité c'est qu'on se
disent tous que c'est pas nous que c'est
les autres que c'est pas ici que c'est
loin et que c'est pas si grave
bon du coup on va rentrer dans la partie
un peu cuit pas luisant de la
présentation mais si c'est nous et c'est
grave c'est nos péchés c'est nous qui
produisons c'est nous qui achetons c'est
nous qui consommons et c'est nous qui
jetons et c'est ça la réalité
bon maintenant qu'on a mis un peu tout
ça à plat
moi je vais vous dire que j'y crois que
je crois en cette utopie que je crois en
ce monde meilleur et pour ça vous
rappelle qu'il faut toujours que vous
aussi vous m'aidiez à réaliser mon rêve
donc il faut qu'on y croit tous ensemble
qu'on croit à cette réalité à cette
utopie pardon et qu'on évolue alors
évoluer oui mais la vraie question c'est
comment
parce qu'attention je dis pas qu'il faut
plus s'habiller manger consommer acheter
se déplacer et tous ces verbes ans et je
dis simplement qu'il faut réfléchir
réfléchir et agir de la meilleure
manière
personnellement ça m'a pris quand même
pas mal de temps à prendre conscience de
tout ça et à savoir comment faire par
quel bout commencer
donc pour que vous vous alliez plus vite
que moi je vous propose de vous montrer
un peu de des manières de fonctionner de
manière de réfléchir de penser dans
certaines situations
la première situation c'est quand vous
avez besoin de quelque chose
j'ai besoin de quelque chose qu'est ce
que je fais je me demande si c'est
nécessaire et la première des choses à
faire c'est de refuser de refuser
d'acheter neuf et vous avez le pouvoir
de refuser d'acheter est la deuxième des
choses à faire c'est de trouver une
alternative et d'agir dans le bon sens
d'emprunter de mutualiser de réparer
d'acheter d'occasion
prendre un exemple j'ai besoin de faire
un trou dans mon mur j'ai besoin d'une
perceuse et ben la première chose à
faire c'est de se dire je n'ai pas
besoin je refuse d'acheter une perceuse
neuf et je trouve une alternative
je fais autrement je peut l'emprunter à
mon voisin je peux la mutualiser la
louer dans un magasin de bricolage
je peux réparer l'ancien de mes grands
parents où je peux acheter une perceuse
d'occasion et derrière la redonner la
revendre lui redonner une deuxième voire
une troisième vie la seconde des
situations c'est quand vous avez plus
besoin de quelque chose
finalement le moment où vous allez jeter
et ben la première des choses à faire
c'est pareil c'est de refuser de jeter
et la seconde chose à faire c'est pareil
aussi de trouver une alternative
vous pouvez donnez vous pouvez vendre
vous verrez utiliser et vous pouvez
valoriser recyclés ou compostés
là aussi si on peut si on prend un
exemple par exemple reprenons notre
fameux jean première chose je refuse de
jeter
surtout quand je sais tout ce qui s'est
passé derrière deuxième chose je trouve
une alternative
je peux le donne et je peux le vendre je
peux s'il est trop abîmé le découper en
faire autre chose où je peux le recycler
pour que par exemple ils deviennent un
matériau pour isoler un bâtiment et le
jour où il sera parfaitement éco-conçus
je pourrais peut-être le composter rien
de bien compliqué on est d'accord
finalement si vous appliquez ces deux
principes 1
je refuse 2 je fais autrement
vous allez voir que vous allez changer
votre vie en mieux
[Musique]
pour conclure je voudrais vous parler
d'une dernière notion celle de
l'économie circulaire
parce que finalement si vous appliquez
un je refuse 2 je trouve une alternative
vous allez faire de l'économie
circulaire et vous allez pouvoir
l'appliquer dans votre vie perso dans
votre vie pro et en tant que citoyen et
finalement il s'agit simplement de
réfléchir de manière systémique globale
et d'avoir le moins d'impact possible de
s'inspirer tout simplement de la nature
de créer notre propre cycle le cycle de
l'homme sans doute je m'appelle maëlys
hier kasun j'ai 25 ans et pour évoluer
vers ce monde de demain j'ai créé mon
métier pour montrer les solutions pour
guider ce changement est pour passer à
l'action
je suis consultante en économie
circulaire et j'accompagne les
particuliers les entreprises et les
territoires à aller vers ce monde vers
cette économie de demain mais je n'y
arriverai pas seul
c'est à nous tous aujourd'hui de changer
c'est à nous tous d'évoluer
c'est à nous de rêver et c'est à nous
d'imaginer notre utopie pour que demain
elle soit notre réalité
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]